what happened you've lost five million
dollars yeah which one you see you look
at the list tell them which one you
wanna do what happened you've lost five
million dollars all right I didn't
exactly lose $5 but I did not make the
five million dollars that I could have
made all right so this is called Sean's
shitty investments this is a new segment
we created just now and I'll tell you
about two bad investments in one good
investment I made so I was talking to a
friend of mine a guy who had been added
in advising this guy about his startup
this is maybe four five years ago I've
been advising him he didn't live in
America he was building a product for
international his product was around
international students applying to US
universities and making it easy if you
don't know if you live overseas like I
finished high school in China so I saw
this firsthand if you're in China you're
in India you're in Malaysia the goal
like your life goal is to go to a u.s.
University don't even matter if it's a
good one but it's to go to a u.s.
University and you know if US
universities overcharge for for that and
and they get in trouble about -
sometimes yeah actually right now
there's a bunch stuff in the news
because they charge like three times
more for it the state is in trouble
because they have like 60% Chinese
nationals there and they're like right
[__] you guys I've charted 60 grand for
these kids exactly so so anyways I was
helping this guy great founder really
like the company was really interested
but I was at a point at that time
financially where I was like okay if I'm
investing in startups it's a pretty
irresponsible investment because you
know when you invest in startups high
likelihood of failure so you need to
place like 25-30 bets and so if you say
okay I'm gonna place yeah 2530 bets and
each bets gonna be 25 grand like I'm
basically I need to have five hundred
thousand I don't have $750,000 that I'm
gonna put into this which means that
can't be like your whole net worth which
is like well this would that would have
been 75771 50 grand at that time would
have been more than my whole net worth
and so I knew I didn't have the the sort
of bankroll to do it
but that was an excuse I could have
found a way I could have brought the
check anyways I could have banked on
myself making more in the future like I
did and bottom line is I didn't so I
would have been the first check into
this guy's company and my sort of
$25,000 check which I was very very
close to writing would have become a
five million dollar stake in this guy's
business by now wait what's the name of
the company say the name and how big is
it now I'll just tell you the name will
bleep it out so it's called and so he
told me that they just crossed it you
know the billion dollar valuation and
and so I don't know if they're exactly
at that onething a little over a little
under but the point is they're they're
doing well and and so yeah I was kicking
myself because that would have been a
big investment as happened to me this
has happened to me
now two different times where I could
have I could have been one of the angel
checks into a business I thought it was
a good business I didn't pull the
trigger and those two would have
combined to be worth you know ten
million dollars plus by now well calm
yeah so this company this studying
abroad company there do they make a lot
of revenue or is it just yeah reading it
and even then like this was the reprieve
ever knew at the time but I was doing
the math and I was like wait like they
had an LOI signed by a bunch of
universities and I was like wait so if
they just match the supply and demand
like this things there make money do
them enough conviction and it's just a
bleach insight no no it's a full
software tool that let that actually
does the application for the student the
universe money oh it's a SAS company
it's a free SAS tool for the user and
then it's a lead gen on the other side
when a kid gets accepted they get paid
that way got it and they charge the
university's money yeah like thousands
of dollars per student
so okay so they don't charge the money
for the software no the software's used
by the actual student and customer so
anyways it was a it's a great business
big mess on my part happy for the guy
though he's an awesome guy and I really
I like this guy's energy a lot kind of
sometimes you meet people who got could
just have good energy I don't know how
describe it he was one of those peoples
and you know MGM
so not again so basically I haven't
talked about this on the podcast but I
during co vid I decided to mess around
with option trading which you know
famous last words
and so I was literally this is how dumb
I am right so so I don't play in the
finite by the public markets that much I
just do very simple things I just buy
companies I think are good for the next
10 years or i buy index funds I don't do
a whole I don't do like day trading I
don't do their leverage buying or I
don't do shorts but I was like you know
what I don't see any way that MGM which
is MGM Resorts I was like I don't see
any way that their business doesn't go
down with this coded thing and so I was
thinking about it and it got cut by like
75 percent so the stock price dropped
from I don't know it was like 25 dropped
from 30 down to like 12 and then I was
like yeah I still think that this thing
is gonna go down and so I'm literally on
one tab I have like a Khan Academy video
of like what the hell is a put and on
the other hand I've got my Robin Hood
account and I'm like just pushing
buttons and so I pushed a bunch of
buttons and I placed this trade which
basically said okay I think MGM's gonna
go down and yeah about two thousand
dollars worth of options and like let's
see what happens and it turns out MGM
didn't go down but I needed it once I
understood my own trade which was like
after I placed it cuz I was again just
put your buttons
when I was looking at the like
confirmation I was like this is a
horrible trade but I just basically said
that this is gonna go down 40% in the
next seven days did you lose - grab
stupid bet so that's my bad the two bad
investment side of waters here on the
other side other side I bet really big
into Bitcoin and when it dropped to like
4500 recently and now it's back up so
that one made back money from for the
buy shitty option trading in Spain I I
completely stay away from stocks I only
buy S&P 500 or Facebook stock and about
two weeks ago when it was at the bottom
I was like I was like well no when the
whole market was real low like the
lowest point maybe ten or two weeks ago
I sold most everything and I was like I
think I think it's just gonna get worse
and worse and worse because I'm
and unemployment comes out and it's the
highest it's ever been
and/or the unemployment work claims and
then the stock market goes up 20 percent
like I just don't understand how I know
I don't understand how this works at all
because and then I applied for the loan
for for Trump enacted and I'm like so
you're telling me we get free money that
sounds great but you start thinking
about it you're like I'm gonna pay for
this eventually like somehow I'm there's
no such thing as free we're gonna pay
for it eventually and so this money it's
just this whole situation it doesn't
make sense to me because the stock
market should be going down yes this is
a dead cat bounce or like sort of a
false rally but forgetting forgetting
the market right now because I don't
know [__] about it and who also who
cares it's not that interesting
it's a speculators game though there's a
phrase I learned that I thought was
pretty cool it's called a king Xena
contest you know to Kenzie and beauty
contest is okay so have you ever heard
of that sort of economists full names
like Maynard John Maynard Keynes or
whatever anyways he's famous guy in the
world of economics Keynesian economics
and a Keynesian Brede beauty contest
describes this phenomenon where let's
say there's a know what you think the
stock market should be is here's an
asset here's a company you can buy some
of their stock and you buy it if you
think that the companies are can have
become more valuable than it's priced at
today that's what we think should be
happening but what's actually happening
is this is a speculator market rights a
speculation driven market and so you
don't in in a short time horizon you
don't you're not betting that the
company is going to improve and actually
generate more revenue and whatnot you're
just betting that other people are gonna
think this is more attractive but
they're also bidding that other people
are gonna think you're attractive suits
kingsy beauty contest is where you're
not actually judging the beauty of it
you are thinking what the other judges
would think about this thing and they're
thinking about what the other jesters
think about this thing and it becomes a
sort of speculative loop and that's my
sort of Wikipedia page of the week
that's exactly how things working and it
just annoys me so much you have so much
more control over your life when you
actually run the business right and
there's also a great phrase which is
sort of in the short-term the stock
market is a popular
lady contest and in the long term it's a
weighing machine and I think that really
describes it well right so like is this
also for private companies as well and
when you're you're raising a Series A in
your hyped company it's a popularity
contest and what people like how did
this valuation that doesn't make any
sense like yeah it makes sense if you if
you understand that this is currently a
popularity contest but over the long
haul it does not remain a popularity
contest it becomes a weighing machine
and if you're full of air and there's
nothing there like your value will go
down and so for all those people who
don't understand those valuations that's
why it's frustrating
I'm just so I don't I don't do anything
in that world because I just know I I
don't know anything about it and I don't
want to know like it makes me too angry
[Music]